hi everyone I'm John's insurance here at  the studio at the st. Louis chess club  and today I have another tactical puzzle  for you so go ahead and pause your video  when you see the puzzle and we'll see if  you can solve it in this position it's  black to move are you ready for the  solution here it comes  in this position black is able to take  advantage of whites weak back rank and  win a piece by playing the move Queen  takes Bishop in white is best advice not  to take the Queen because if he plays  rook takes Queen black now has the move  rook to a1 check and the only way to  avoid mate is to give away all of your  pieces including your rook and now white  would be checkmated  thank you for watching congratulations  to all of you they were able to solve  the puzzle today if you want to see more  great content like this please subscribe  to our youtube channel thank you for  watching